[Music]
we're not holding up
because it's episode 100.
[Music]
let's get creepy though
it's crazy that like a thing the size of
a tiny like
solar calculator was able to do all that
audio distortion
um technology is changing our lives
episode 100 oh yeah this is episode 100.
all right guys it's episode 100
what's going on 100 wow
sam apparently found uh an updated an
updated version of his
voice modulator thing that he
that he famously had and then if you
look at an old vlog when we went to nab
one year
sam has like an original version of that
thing and
he's making all these weird songs in the
car
and now we're doing it here remixing
your baby oh yeah
yeah but yeah they they make little
rubber cases
but i remember it being like all exposed
circuitry it's the teenage engineering
pocket operator this one's the speak one
because it has all the cool
vocal filters in it that's why i
specifically got it because
i wanted it for a while and uh i had
another one that broke
it got beat up and so if you want the
beats you got to get the the
beat modulator oh he's got the beats
i got the beats was that
was that the beginning of like uh an old
corridor video
or oh yeah first video you hear a little
bit coming through right there
that's the second time footloose has
come out up in conversation today
basically
that's the second time when we're
looking at all the 3d scans of ourselves
that's right it comes up in conversation
every day yeah
honestly it does i don't recall talking
about footloose at all today
that's how we actually start every
conversation over here you just go hey
do you remember footloose do you
remember that scene in footloose okay so
anyways i was
i was at the bank yeah yeah oh yeah
that's right
what makes this episode special other
than having
triple digits i mean
that's there's five people there's
usually not
five people dude i guess i mean i i
forget that you were probably here
and listening to all that earlier jake
because i wasn't listening to you
uh because i didn't have my ear plug in
but i thought i just assumed i was on
the podcast today i came down here all
ready to do it and everyone's like why
are you here i'm like oh
excuse me why are you here existential
crisis no
no it's great that you're here right
playing yourself yeah yeah
no i love the initiative man
i spent the last like few minutes before
coming down here getting jordan up to
speed so that he can like take care of
the next hour
uh so that we have like a goal post to
hit by the time i get out of the podcast
and then i went back upstairs and i was
like
i guess i'm not on the podcast and then
i
came back downstairs i guess i'm on the
podcast
when we first started when we first
started doing the podcast we had a lot
of guests on
yeah and we were doing like highlights
and stuff like that on the youtube
channel on top of like the podcast
episodes
and like halfway through like nah
now it's just us and it's just i mean
for the podcast and that's it
you can see the evolution of it if you
if you watch through like every five
episodes or so
you can see how we've kind of gotten
better at at doing it and finding
our like conversational niches and
i don't know just a lot i mean because
there's a it's basically a live
conversation even though
we don't actually po publish it well
we're recording it we publish it
right basically the next day it's still
you know we don't cut anything and so
even when we're doing the vlogs and that
camera was on you for the first time
the the the fallback was that oh well
hey at least we can cut it
[Laughter]
not not really anymore so we have the
flexibility to cut something if we
need to yeah i mean obviously but
still i think it's better to just keep
it just let it run
and uh yeah i mean it's fine talking to
someone one-on-one for like two hours
and like not stopping it's really hard
yes it is like
usually i like to have like 10 to 15
minute conversations
with people and we'll talk and i'll be
like i need a break i'm gonna do
something else for a little bit wait
wait wait can we can we do can we have
sam have his own podcast that's 10 to 15
minute sequences called i need a break
i need a break from you and then you
don't upload for a week
and whenever you're done with the
conversation you just go
thanks i need a break and then you just
and then that's great i'm going to do
something else for a bit
like i'm going to refill i'm going to
take a break and go to the bathroom you
know all the things you say at a party
to get out of talking to yeah that's
cool
hey uh i'm going to take a lap
that's my line yeah i'll make a lap see
who's here
i'm going to go check out the beer
situation great talking
i'm going to see if anyone else is here
that i know
okay
yeah what if we were just on the podcast
like hey all right i'm done talking to
you later this conversation
has no value yeah right now i'm at my
friend's party and i don't really know
you that well so i'm going to go hang
out with my friend
it's pretty real so uh what do you come
here often
uh yeah i live here um oh you came to my
house for this party
oh um so how long have you been living
here
um that's funny yeah you go to someone
else's house party and you're the first
to arrive he's like is anyone else
showing up
if not this could be awkward i kind of
forget what party small talk is like
i haven't had to make it for so long
yeah now all the small talks just about
covid like
oh man glad this is almost over huh yeah
yeah me too talk about that instead of
the weather i know i know it's a really
coveted free day today
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like yeah how
about that doctor virus up there
it's flying in
uh so has a hundred episodes of
podcasting made all of you guys better
conversationalists no it's i think it's
made me a better conversationalist i
i feel yeah maybe just a little bit here
too
i mean i feel like all of our our videos
that we've made on the crew channel for
the last five years have made me a
better conversation
that's true it gives you a lot of
interesting things to talk about
yeah i know like the rooster teeth guys
they have a rule that you can never have
a pause someone always has to be talking
and i know gus
has like developed a really fine skill
of like the moment like a fraction of a
moment he
feels a hesitation he's already got a
new thing to say hmm
and that's because he's you know been
doing that for a long time
i wonder if that has
i wonder if that has actual merit though
like for
a value of a podcast like what what if
there is
what if there's what if we all just
decided not to say anything for five
seconds
what happened it's just too much like a
real competition
why get this out of here
i mean if you come to the corridor why
why
is the silence so awkward yeah because i
feel like you have an innate urge
to fill the silence and yet that's
butting up against
your lack of knowing what to say all
right guys here we go three two one
all right i can't take it anymore i
can't take it anymore well that's why
people come to the corner
it's like a real conversation it's
awkward because we were specifically
doing it as opposed to being like all
right
like the most awkward side like this is
closet in the back it's like
one of you guys and me both went into
that closet there and shut the door
and said like like and then we go and
see how long it takes
for us to say something that's true i
think
quietly staring at another person and
staring at you and like just feeling
this immense pressure building
to do something i'm gonna go take a lap
there's like a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
see who else is here i'm gonna see if
there's anywhere else i can put my feet
in this closet
this is a great fit this is a great
closet but uh i'm gonna go take a lap to
the one upstairs
uh so uh how long should we stay in this
closet do you think
it can come it's almost over yeah yeah
so did you wear masks
i don't know anymore did you get the
visor or the modern if you have it in
this closet i'm definitely going to get
it because we're way too close
there we go that's a great simulated
closet conversation right there
now we know what to say do you think it
has anything to do with like
uh human vulnerability where like if
you're talking to somebody that you
don't know
and then there's you don't say anything
it's like
is there that moment where you think is
this person gonna murder me right now
you know is it like that primal thing i
run that every day
every time i'm talking to sam maybe
that's it
every time there's a silence it's just
like we have to fill it or else
someone gets murdered
that's where it comes from and here's
evolution that's there's a lot of
science behind it yeah if you do the
research
you will come to that conclusion you
guys played the game keep talking and
nobody dies
yep explain it keep talking nobody
explodes yeah that's the one
the bomb game the bomb game yeah we do
that in a real
game it's a video game where one percent
is a bomb and somebody else has the
manual
it's a game you can like play with your
parents it's accessible enough for that
even though it's technically a video
game we did that once on node where we
had uh
radios and one team had like the bomb
manual and radios and their team had
the bomb aka the computer and a radio
and like a you know
bomb vest and they had to disarm it by
talking over the radio to the bomb techs
it was very very challenging actually
because radios aren't uh two-way
simultaneous communication devices so in
the real world
in the real world you should use your
phone because the radio you talk but you
can't hear them talking
until you stop yeah so heavily it's
facing over
that's true that's why you said it is
right that you are done talking and then
if you're done with the
and if you're done with the conversation
you say over and out also the other
thing is
on a phone so that's the party line now
[Laughter]
hey what's the difference between copy
that and roger that
same thing oh gosh is it the same thing
as far as i've known i i don't know
radiolingual that well
but i i don't think either of them are
official terms
i just remember i i don't even know how
many years ago it was at this point but
i made a comment some
it was a i was in a youtube comment
thread responding to someone
and my final comment was copy that and
then i hit post and i was like wait no i
think i should have said roger that
right
and i went and i edited it and i typed
roger that and hit save
and i was like i did i is that the right
word i don't know whatever
i came back the next day and there was a
response from the guy being like did you
just
did you did you change it
[Laughter]
when you're asking somebody a question
on radio you can
common lingo you can say how copy as in
like
do you copy cool radio guys always like
have weird grammatical
like yeah like oddities like how coffee
yeah or just like
roger this is ghost rider one night
yeah sandblaster two how are you doing
out there how copy
you have to have this you know
everything you say roger that yeah
you know kind of like uh no just not
really funny actually like
it was like i heard about this in the
podcast
[Laughter]
yeah world war one there was this the 13
year old boy he snuck aboard a
vessel over to germany and uh they
realized that this 13 year old kid named
roger had snug aboard and joined the
ranks in the world war one battalion
and so rather than give him a gun they
turned him into the like the ammo boy
who would
run ammunition up and down the trenches
and he would always say
yes sir yes sir yes sir and soon or
sooner or later they realized he was
like one of the most affirmative
people on the battlefield
they eventually died
so that's when you're going to get hit
by sniper fire you say roger that
yeah i'm going to cheers
i think it's a pretty close version of
what really happened okay
yeah it sounds like it definitely sounds
like it
yeah all right that's a cool story sam i
i feel like
your dungeon mastering has
helped you be a good storyteller yeah as
long as like i just need to learn how to
not
laugh before i start trying to like fake
people out
then then it would work better oh well
yeah hey uh right i've been curious what
your uh
give me give me your hot take on that
virgin galactic
oh yeah that little space launch that
happened can you preface it with what
happened
so richard branson and virgin galactic
which is basically set up as a space
tourism
company did their first like
public-facing launch uh on sunday with
richard branson on board and uh it's a
suborbital flight so it goes up 250
000 feet uh so it's still technically in
the atmosphere uh
50 miles 50 miles up i believe that's
000 feet roughly 50 thousand feet yeah
250.
so 50 000 miles about 50 50 miles
50 miles they went up 50 miles uh it
does a little backflip and you get some
weightlessness and you come back down
and it's pretty neat
um and then everybody i see online is
just talking so much [ __ ] about it
so i'm i'm curious is suborbital flight
space
is that why they're talking [ __ ] because
it's it's sub-orbital meaning it's like
isn't that like the technical problem
here is that the karman line is about
100 miles up and that's kind of the
internationally recognized
a boundary between our atmosphere and
outer space
why didn't we just call it space line
um carmen invented it
i mean i don't know uh the dude i don't
know what the name origin of carmen
comes from sure but yeah space but
that's 100 miles
a hundred miles all right we'll go with
that one
why not i mean though is that like
basically the the virgin galactic
flyer was just do you guys know the
vomit comment the the airplane that
allows people to go waitlist because
they go
up really quickly and then they go down
at the same speed as
you can fall so from the relative
standpoint of the walls around you
you're in free fall therefore you're
weightless so you can like bounce around
and whatnot
the virgin galactic plane basically did
that on steroids it went
really high up and is coming back down
really fast so you have a lot more
time to experience weightlessness but
that's all it is it's just
it's just that it's kind of going up and
down people always confuse going into
like outer space like satellites rocket
ships they just go straight up
but the thing about you know orbit
you know you know the name orbit orbit
implies going around something so
you only go up for a small ways and then
you go sideways and
build up enough speed until you're
basically just constantly falling and
you never fall back down to the earth
virgin galactic did not do that um and
so
i'm not joining the rest of the internet
to
make fun of them but i also don't really
care that much
i don't know it was just kind of like i
didn't look into it i didn't read much
into it over the weekend i kind of
didn't care
but i'm not going to bash virgin
galactic i'm
for for trying to do this they're
pushing technology forward in order to
do something and that technology that
they're pushing is eventually going to
make its way
to help other industries other
pursuits somehow in ways we don't yet
understand you know that's
the whole thing about how i think nasa
deserves a lot more money is because
all the stuff they're doing is
eventually going to make its way into
some other technology that'll make our
lives better
um i could not care less about the
billionaires in charge i don't care
uh if they want to have their ego
contest like sure
i wanna i mean hey at least i'm making
rockets and going to space i mean yeah
and
and it's fine but is that why people are
being salty about it though is because
it's just
like billionaire boys club up there
pretty much
yeah i mean because the main thing is
that there's this
it's now a rivalry between the three
billionaires who have space companies
jeff bezos
elon musk and uh the other dude's name
richard branson richard branson thank
you
uh i like richard richard as a as a
character
i think he's amusing yes he is sir yeah
but yeah i mean i jeff bezos though has
another rocket company
and he they threw out this whole thing
basically throwing a ton of shade
at virgin galactic i mean like oh
technically the internationally
recognized line
is way up here and you're only going to
hear so it doesn't really count there's
an asterisk next to all the
astronauts in your ship it's like okay
i now hate you you're the you're
that guy so but yeah i don't know
what it comes down to is for me it
doesn't count unless you're in orbit
i think that idea of seeing like
continents float by at the speed
of like corn not the side of the window
your car yeah
yeah like that would be pretty neat that
would be crazy
is that what you get from suborbital you
don't quite get that you probably can
you can probably see really far you can
see far but it's not going to be moving
out underneath you because you're not
going sideways that far
this one got them back yeah it's
literally just a parabola you go up
and you experience weightlessness for a
little bit and then you get weight back
as you come in for a gliding landing can
you see the
curvature of the planet at least yeah
you're high enough
up at that height you totally can at 50
miles up you totally can
it's just you know your field of view is
still relatively small
it's like you have this little cone down
below you and that's pretty much it
whereas when you're in orbit
you're pretty much up there forever not
including any sort of like drag you
might have in the atmosphere to pull you
back down but turn into a space skeleton
yeah what you're normally forever
are there any space skeletons up there
well no
there's a few there's there's a there's
some stories of these
russian astronauts that made the
ultimate sacrifice
there's some really crazy and weird uh
yeah that's right conspiracy theory
yeah well they probably came back into
the atmosphere anything that's
do you think there's any like actual
bodies that have that are still up in
space
i feel like they've escaped the
atmosphere well and yeah the thing about
it is that there is no
actual hard line between the end of the
atmosphere
and deep space it's just it's a gradient
that is so
fine it just goes out for like hundreds
and hundreds of miles
i suppose you can depend on a number of
other factors too like your weight and
your velocity and your
movement i mean yeah and so all the but
that atmosphere out there even though
you're technically in outer space even
though there's like
literally nothing around you there's
still enough that over
however many years even if it's like
dozens hundreds or thousands of years
every little like hydrogen atom hitting
you over enough time will slow your
momentum down enough that you start
falling back
into the atmosphere and it's a it's a
cycle that builds upon itself like a
compounding thing the more resistance
you get the further you slow down then
the more
resistance you get and eventually burn
up yeah
oh hey welcome to the time in the
podcast where i tell you about today's
sponsor storyblocks i was just under my
desk
searching for the best quality 4k b-roll
audio assets music motion graphics and
after effects templates
and i couldn't find anything under there
because well guess what
the website storyblocks.com is not under
my desk it's
it's behind me on the computer on the
internet we like them over here because
we use them all the time which makes
this
integration and me telling you about
them more symbiotic and harmonious
you may have seen the james bond video
that we just released earlier this week
well
in that video we used a bunch of audio
assets
and music that we got from storyblocks
because
it was an unlimited royalty-free
all-access plan that allowed us to
download as much from the site as we
wanted
and to monetize it on youtube however we
wanted and you can get this plan for
yourself
say you're an amateur creator and you
just want another tool in your tool kit
to be able to create more efficiently
and use your time better and not have to
spend time looking under your desk
for b-roll that's not even going to be
there they're constantly updating their
library
so you're never exhausting the same
types of content that you might need to
be pulling from there
you can literally save yourself hours of
time just by going in there and
downloading it and guess what it's going
to be in high quality 4k
it's a great relationship huge thank you
to them for sponsoring this podcast
head on over to storyblocks.comcast if
you want to get started
that's storyblocks.com corridor cast
now back to the episode damn son
but i mean spaceships are cool the end
cremation via space
that's cool that's how i want to go i
kind of get buried in space like launch
me out there bro let me like spook some
alien somewhere in like a million years
that'd be cool
organic uh contamination of the rest of
the solar system
yeah yeah that's what i'm i'm
pro-organic contamination of the solar
system guys
oh wait no no no sorry to just to talk
on that there was i believe an
actor from star trek who was cremated
and his ashes were sent to space
and ejected into deep space wow that's i
don't know not deep space
that's cool for aliens though i feel
like you know having a
can of ashes i'd rather have a full
carcass
give the aliens like that's like the
ultimate
scam
swindle it's like you pretend to be a
space guy
your whole life to the point where you
convince
real space guys to bring you into space
[Laughter]
[Music]
i forget which guy was i don't think it
was leonard nimoy i think it was someone
older than that uh patrick stewart
he's still with us you sure
and he's sure he's not spirits he
thickens he's in space dude
you heard it here yeah hey what whatever
happened to that chinese rocket that
went out of
out of control did that thing hit the
ocean hit somewhere in the indian ocean
or something like that
did it okay i mean china is also not
known for their space regulations they
commonly drop rockets on villages
it's it's a known thing it's not okay
wow i heard they were dumping
uh they were driving human human sewage
into the south china sea
hold on here are you talking about space
no hold on i want to talk about this
[Laughter]
well i mean because it's like you know
now everyone has a smartphone so
videos of these incidents are you know
increasing and
basically the first stage of a rocket is
designed to come back to the earth it's
not meant to go into outer space
most of a rocket is literally just to
get you up just enough so that the
second rocket can actually taken into
orbit
but that first rocket just falls back
into land and that's why we've always
had
rocket launches out of florida because
it uses the the direction of earth's
rotation
and it's right next to the ocean so it
just goes straight out from florida
over the ocean and the rockets just are
i don't even know how many rockets are
literally at the bottom of the ocean off
the coast of florida
spacex pioneered uh having those rockets
come back and landing so that they could
use it again
yeah it's not universal china they're
just like we're just gonna put a rocket
launch in the middle of our huge
continent
and uh yolo to everyone else yeah no i
just
literally you just youtube chinese
rocket hits village and there's a cell
phone footage of this like oh my gosh
burning building and then
space debris all over the place and the
worst part is that all of the
the fuel is incredibly toxic and it gets
it gets uh airborne the moment like it
crashes and so everyone like in the
vicinity like they breathe in this stuff
and they can burn their lungs they can
have like lasting health problems it's
pretty bad
and they're just doing that water
the edge of the like the ocean there
yeah good question
oh well you know that was really scary
to think about man having a government
that just
is throws all that caution to the wind
and will literally stomp out any i mean
if it wasn't for that
cell phone video i doubt we would know
about that and that orange cloud i doubt
we would know anything about that
that's crazy that's pretty crazy that's
pretty messed up that's a pretty
wacky thing uh yeah hopefully
one word yeah it's like you're just
showing up
from rocket fuel jeez
yeah i mean it's that's what was that
about sewage in the
south china sea okay yeah there was a
story this week that uh
there was a bunch of ships that um
there's some debate over the south china
sea
and uh apparently yeah some
and uh apparently they they had a bunch
of ships down there
and they were dumping um sewage like
into the ocean
um i mean isn't that what we all do
though kind of like
don't ships just dump their wait were
these ships like carrying extra sewage
it wasn't just like today's
giant barge is full of sewage chinese
boat fill up with poop asap
let me look real quick it was worse than
just like
somebody's yacht you know but you don't
even do that
tank here and there you pump them out
when you're at port yeah are you sure
is the legal fecal count for like for
like
seawater like i i know that like there's
usually a good amount of feces in in
seawater if you go swimming at the beach
well currently in l.a
there's a high amount of feces because
the sewage plant had a blockage and you
do an emergency runoff
into the water here we go visible from
space human waste sewage wastewater
dumped by china onto the
south china sea philippines to probe
report of china
hold on viewable from space are we
talking about like
space that's pretty legendary we're
talking about
or is this just an airplane that's a
little higher than normal this is from
reuters okay philippines to probe report
of chinese sewage dumping at sea
well isn't that nasty i think it's
pronounced reuters either way
um that sucks so intense you can see it
from space
so smelly you can smell it from 100
miles away
what are they what's going on that's how
they should be
just how far away can you smell it
that's the
that's what we all want that's what we
want to know you can see it and smell it
from space
wow through a vacuum but also for real
there is actually a
huge uh human waste spill that happened
today
on the beaches south from santa monica
down to like uh
segundo oh dang yeah no swimming for a
little bit
oh man no no no no stay out of the
water's cancelled
yeah summer is cancelled the whole city
just goes
it's just well there's there's a uh it's
the
same treatment they have there and then
yeah there's a blockage
um
illegal paper it's because of the wipes
dude
the non-flexible wipes that got flushed
yeah jake got it finally thank you
uh anyways yeah so they had they had to
do an emergency overflow which goes into
the ocean
which honestly i get it you have an
emergency don't blow up the whole plant
so it's like and it is a water treatment
plant it's doing what we have
right
oh god um it's like a big blender
it's like chernobyl
makes a video
[Laughter]
yeah there's like this deep rumbling in
the factory and everyone starts sweating
oh no
and then it cuts to the inside of the
chambers and things start exploding do
you ever anyone see clearwater horizon
that movie the michael bay movie by the
way
yeah yeah yeah deep brown resin yeah i
ended up seeing a part or two of it or
something but um it's okay you can tell
us that you watch the whole thing
yeah you don't need to be invited let's
just say i watch the whole thing
but like there's a great scene in that
that you could totally intercut with a
news story about this where they're in
this like little room with pipes and
they all start like blowing up
there's like brown water everywhere and
they're like wait
whoa anyways
that's what is happening in my
imagination there's a re-edit there's
somebody
back and forth between that and the news
anchor going there's a whole bunch of
poop out in the ocean
it's just the tsunami i know they're
like slapping out to the window and like
just streaking their hands i mean
obviously the actual oil
thing is you know tragic and all but
it's funny if it's ppe
this is this is from the la times uh
swarms of chinese vessels have dumped
human waste for
and waste water for years into a
disputed area of the
south china sea causing lj booms that
have damaged coral reefs and
algae algae yeah and an unfolding
as they eat it right up satellite images
over the last five years have shown
how human waste sewage and wastewater
have accumulated and caused algae in a
cluster of reefs
there's a software company creating ai
technologies for satellite image
analysis which has of course they are
this is i feel like this is the
meta equivalent of like two tribes of of
apes
right a hundred thousand years ago
coming up to each other and just like
throwing poop throwing their poop at
each other
that is actually exactly what it is
that's what's happening in real time
ships were spotted
to be able to identify poopoo
oh my gosh you can just look at the
pictures man look the computer
we're laughing about this but this is
like ren hit the nail on the head this
is
that is literally what this is it's like
oh is this here south china sea oh well
sorry i'm gonna
seem to like my [ __ ] i'm gonna poop i'm
gonna poop all over it
that's so gross why don't you do
something about it
yeah yeah i mean they're bordering right
up against vietnam there and it's like
they're constantly trying to encroach
further and further into
their waters and land yeah they're doing
it everywhere i mean
yeah they're in south america doing it
have you seen those crazy pictures off
of argentina
no that's wait what fishing ships wasn't
it it's
legitimately creepy as hell it's like
no joke there's like 50 fishing vessels
that go down to south america and create
this like massive troll that
like uh like they're all they all have
their nets out basically
and they the ships stick right next to
each other and someone
took a private plane like a politician
down there got a private jet
and flew over the area to basically do
reconnaissance and found
one of the fleets and got photos of it
and it's like 50 boats
all right next to each other this like
massive huge line and they're all just
like
like combing and fishing let's just kill
everything china that sounds like
they're bringing all the fish back
yeah yeah they're like that's how far
out of like yeah they're in argentinian
waters doing it
it's pretty like let's tear the game
risk
i i don't know i feel like we're living
that right now of like it's like
i don't know just say everything feels
so first world all the time but you see
that's something like oh
like we have a country that's like going
to other countries and like stealing
stuff and trying not to get in trouble
dude which country is going to be the
first one to flip the game board
that's no question you need to flip the
game board on mother nature and boys
it'll be mother nature yeah and
the fires are starting i've been saying
it for months this year is going to be
probably the worst year for fires
the fuel moisture content is at a record
level it's all kindling out there right
now
yeah it's pretty wild how hot it got up
north
yeah it's just about to start here in
l.a it's just starting
things are just about do you sound like
the wacky scientist and like all the
disaster movies
things like that what's gonna happen
from independence day yeah yeah it's
actually been very pleasant in l.a
it is all time nice it's been really
nice it's been like just you wait nico
it's been a little on the hot side but
we're also in july that's what
i predicted it was gonna feel nice and
temperate wait a minute this map can't
be right
according to my calculations there's no
water in any of these plants
it's impossible well even last year with
all the bad fires we had there was more
moisture in those plants
there's less moisture in them this year
yeah
sam what are you whispering over here
wait what this is the ai
i programmed this ai to look at
satellite images
[Laughter]
people are like what no it's funny
this is funny
[Music]
no listen to it filtered and quiet
[Laughter]
a little more when it's like when the
bit's happening yeah
there we go all right anyway this one
all right so
we just listened to that for like a full
minute okay
rand you're working on uh this little
challenge for this yeah
so clint launched a new render challenge
he did one
a couple months ago that blew up i've
never seen anything get like 170
000 up votes on reddit and his video did
uh obviously it was the culmination of a
lot of artists work but
we're participating in the new one or
see at least myself and
another artist upstairs uh we're trying
to make something and in the process
i dive further into so for those who do
not know
what are these challenges all about
basically clint creates a project file
that's incredibly stripped and bare
bones
it's designed to loop it's designed to
be something that everyone can open
and there's some rules in play like
you're not allowed to alter the camera
you're not allowed to alter the scene
geometry
but you have these time frames so like
for instance this one is
i think it's called the dynamics the
dynamic machines challenge
basically he's trying to create the
world's largest cg root goldberg machine
and the idea is that at a certain frame
you have like something like 500 frames
and let's say like frame 100 something
uh a ball
a little metal chrome ball drops into
your box
and you're just supposed to have it do
stuff because at another frame later on
say hypothetically it's frame 350 it has
to exit
and it has to very specifically enter
and exit on those frames
so that it can go into the next uh slot
and but you then
you have to continue rendering out your
videos so it like is able to
play off screen and the idea is that
it's just one box after another box
after another just
infinitely as many renders as you have
they just they play out
it's a really cool idea and it allows
just to kind of like cool
like make some cool little simulations
of a ball going around like a ramp and
some stuff and then eventually you can
have it like come into the box and then
split into 100 other smaller balls and
then bounce around and then come back
into the same one
i thought about that uh something like
fracturing it and having it do
different things i've already had like
100 different ideas but we've settled on
one
so uh this guy we have upstairs uh his
name is jordan
him and i've been working together on
this he's been cranking away on learning
this new thing in houdini so that he can
teach me
i don't know if i want to talk about it
just yet i always say don't give away
the concept yet
yeah i won't i won't talk about the
concept yet but if if i can learn how to
do this that's a big level up for me
yeah so
you're just face to face with the beast
right now
kind of well not quite yet that's
probably going to start tomorrow and the
day after because it's like
he had to figure out how to do this
thing in houdini
first yeah and then he's going to teach
me how to do it so right now i'm still
just kind of like
a lot of brainstorming the last like day
and a half just about a lot of things
but also just kind of like like like
like like like like like like like like
assets how's he gonna composite these
all together
he was like on the submission guidelines
he's like you have to send me an mp4
or an h.264 file yeah yeah it's gonna
need alpha channels isn't it yeah
he needs alpha channels no he's uh clint
was telling me about this he's already
got this whole like script
in place that basically uh attaches
it turns all of the different
submissions into pre comps with a
a track mat over them okay so they they
seem sorry are seamlessly
put together and also timed out at the
correct spacing makes sense
yeah because i had the same question i
asked like what is it yeah i want to do
it one where the ball comes down and
like
hits like almost just almost perfectly
hits the hole and then doesn't
and it just sits there like that's it
it's just like three seconds it's like
it's just like just kind of like a
finger comes and pushes it down the
whole
the theory i heard you uh you crashed a
stream and then
proceeded to play against him in this
glorious moment of my life
yeah no like i you know clint streams on
his youtube channel every saturday
morning and i was like in bed just like
on my computer and
uh i had the stream on in the background
and he started talking about smash and i
i typed in i like to participate in the
stream i was like clint you're trash at
smash you're smash trash
and of course that got him going oh i
will three stalk you any day son
and it kept going i was like it got to a
point like literally jenna was chilling
in bed next to me again
saturday morning and i was like i i have
to i have to go over there now
i have to i have to go to his house
all right i'm gonna have to go i'm gonna
have to go teach clinton a lesson so i
got in my car
and i'm driving over there uh and i told
him i messaged him like as i'm driving
over there
at a red light wasn't texting and
driving i'm on my way see in a minute
he's like oh okay
uh yeah i got there like just as the
stream was finishing
and he uh we hooked up
the smash games real quick i just i'm
gonna you're not gonna be able to see
this you didn't fight him live on the
stream
we did we did so we managed to hook up
uh the switch to the stream it took a
few minutes to get it set up
uh but clint was so confident that he
was gonna destroy me
and i'm gonna play the final 10 seconds
of our first battle
the final 10 seconds of our first battle
hold on while you're doing this gotta go
visit
the south china sea ready
all right oh yeah this is gonna be good
i love your microphone so um
when is oh wait no that's why sorry i
have to get off discord for a moment
anyways so okay ready ready
yeah i'm ready
[Laughter]
and you can find this on his on a stream
from the end of his stream saturday
whatever that day was
uh that's funny july 9th or 10th um
yeah he was so confident he went from
done game
yeah it's all about calling it being
able to call you're like oh you messed
up i got you now
yep and then if you turn it around oh
it's the best wow all right
i'm back on discord now that's funny i'm
i'm glad you did that
yeah that's always the best when you can
manage like a nice underdog
moment but then he proceeded to beat me
the next two games so he got best
still you didn't just come in and get
trounced i didn't get three sucked no
yeah
they were close games but he won yeah
yeah we've been playing a lot of smash
we've all been collectively getting a
lot better at smash two i was hanging
out with a bunch of friends last month
uh uh that i don't normally see and i
was playing smash bros with them and i
like
destroyed them and i'm not i'm like an
average player
in this building i'm like i'm not the
worst but i'm definitely not the best
but pre we spend so much time playing
this game
that i forget that most people don't
play this game as much as we do
like i'm not kidding i probably play at
least an hour of smash bros every single
day
and have been for two and a half years
yeah i still play it for fun at home i'm
like yeah i don't know it's just
so casual let that sink in jake
i know that's no it's not an hour five
hours a week
whatever even if it was
[Laughter]
yeah nico meanwhile has has been keeping
his switch as like the main
switch and so he's just been accruing
all these playtime hours on
yeah we're probably approaching ten
thousand games played oh my god
that's crazy that's amazing yeah but
it's ten thousand dollars become a true
expert
somebody do something god damn it yeah
somebody tried to beat me
wow yeah so next week we have a big old
show
oh yeah that was gonna be i'm excited
yeah we have a big old shoot
it's been a long time coming it's been
very difficult to get here but
it's pretty sweet now and it's the son
of a dungeon green screen shoot
where we're gonna take our live actors
and put them in the
game table environment and uh finally
so it's been a few weeks trying to put
all this stuff together and it's been
kind of
a struggle because like you know uh when
when peter was still here he was like
the other guy in the studio i could
lean on for unreal stuff and now it's
kind of like oh like
you know i'm trying to figure it all out
yeah on top of that over the last few
weeks
the whole like epic games team like went
on vacation so
i had no like actual people to like get
technical support from
real quick to interject we should
probably clarify about peter if we
haven't already peter's on a
long vacation right now he's not he's
not gone he'll be back
i mean we don't like that kind of sounds
like a euphemism or like uh
he he went up to the farm
he's taking a sabbatical that's what he
writes about that's what he's doing he's
like hey
he's taking a gap year we'll see each
other again soon i want to do a personal
project and we're like cool so we did
that
yeah um so but either way out in the
flower
fields breathing that fresh blue air
eating pies out of the prairie every day
with the puppies
and the kittens i don't get this are you
making it peter's dead before
oh yeah peter's dead yeah peter went to
the farm
sorry with all the others anyway so it's
been a while
he meant to travel before uh before he
came on with us but uh then cove had
happened and so now this is his
opportunity to do that
yeah but that means that sam doesn't
have someone to help him with all this
i've officially spent too much time
trying to get this stuff working
but it is all working i feel like in my
optimal world i would have spent like
two less weeks doing this but
oh well you've got a lot of really cool
stuff uh working now
i think probably the biggest thing is
that you have the camera
synchronized with the position of the
in-game camera
yeah it's close it's like 90 percent
close but it's it's like good enough for
you watching you're like okay
this is working for me like like if you
if you
go frame by frame and really analyze it
you'll see
that every once in a while the frames
are like a little faster or slower than
the footage
but are you talking like time sync
position uh yeah it's just like
it's like they're synced up and then
like the background slips just a little
extra i mean it's still moving in the
right direction and everything
but it does drift from time to time but
it's
it's if as long as you keep it handheld
and keep it like
the position randomized effectively you
don't notice it
if you did like a super smooth dolly
move you'd totally see it like you'd be
like smooth
click and you're like oh but i just i
imagine like a really cinematic like
pushing and all of a sudden the
background goes
and you're like huh yeah yeah it's a
risk uh
but it's cool because basically um
once i i mean i can just basically take
everything i did and just make it
like a project file that anyone can just
like basically you plug the camera into
your computer
and then hit go you know maybe drop
all right drop a 3d model into the scene
but like it's to the point where you can
basically open up a project
and hit like two buttons and it would
just work as long as you're using the
right camera configuration
um yeah it's cool but it's yeah that's
it's pretty pretty nice
um so each episode is about an hour long
there's eight episodes
what percentage of each episode would
you guess will have live action covering
it
every episode's gonna have a little bit
of live action um but the episodes
uh the lighter episodes are like 20
shots
20 live action shots and then the
heavier one
is like 40 to 50. um and i guess we
don't know the the length of these shots
but they're all here's the thing though
here's the thing there's natural
limitations
to like okay like you're in this live
green screen environment
uh first off like every character that
you guys interact with is a miniature
and it's not animated
so like there's not a lot of like stuff
we can show with like a person wrestles
a goblin to the ground it's like we're
not going to do that because that would
require
now a goblin costume and in this world
there's like a million characters and
they're all different knives
you know it's like it's like also almost
unfathomable
i'm unfathomable as far as like how much
costume and
does stuff you have to do to actually
turn it into interactive so
rather than utilize the green screen
footage for that type of action
what we're starting to find is like we
just want to see you guys walk into an
area and react to what you're seeing
like that sets up so much for the viewer
because you're like
oh i get it i saw ren there in a tavern
so now everything we listen to
afterwards we're like
runs into tavern like we get it and so
like it's it's lots of those types of
shots of
you know walk up to a thing hey what's
that
you know move on from there or a
character says something dramatic
and you know we have a good table
reactions you know you're playing the
dnd
we have a great reaction but sometimes
the reactions are better if it's like in
character
because then it's like ooh it's like it
just lands a little bit better
um so it's it's basically it's that kind
of stuff it's like
characters establishing themselves in
environments and
they're the mood and then are there
character beats
are there going to be like any moments
like you know that show drunk history
where it's like these are recreations
and are we gonna have to like lip sync
with like us talking at the table
none of that we decided against doing
that so i think it's kind of funny
it could be kind of funny though it's a
matchup blitz it's
it's a lot of stuff to lift drunk
history is what like five or 10 minutes
you know this is eight and a half hours
[Laughter]
yeah so no audio no lip syncing this is
just
here's the characters their reactions
like they're
blocking where they are and then for
select
moments of comedy we you know try and
recreate
some of those moments but i yeah i think
it'll be pretty sweet it's gonna look
really
really cool yeah it's gonna add that
layer
uh that you don't get with any other dnd
con oh and then on top of that last
thing is
um there's equal shots that are
completely cg
as well so like yeah each episode is
gonna i'm just
it's they're really fast to do and set
up
slap in some models of the like npcs
render out like a really great
establishing shot of an area
and then we have that as well for
whatever
you want so that and that stuff like
looks
just looks so good because it's like the
correct
like the models look better with that
distance because that's like how they
were scanned
yeah looking down and into and we have
them
of all the different characters too yeah
which griffin has done
and i've watched the first two episodes
over the past two days
and they're really good like they're
really fun to watch
um they strike a really interesting
balance between like storytelling
and like a little bit of that
live-action suspense you get when like
okay people are figuring it out on the
spot as opposed to being all scripted
like it actually plays
like i don't go to improv theater very
often and when i say very often i mean
never
and uh and it's mainly i'm sure it's
great and there's like some really good
stuff but there's just something about
like
watching people make it up on the spot
that is not appealing to me
i feel the exact opposite no don't get
me wrong like whose line is anyways is
like the funniest tv show i've ever
watched
it does require talented improvisers to
be able to like make it good
yeah and there's something like
something magical that happens when it
does like when it hits and it comes
together
and like i feel like d and d kind of
strikes this unique balance where a lot
of it is planned out
but at the same time you're still making
your own story beats within it and
you know at least these first two
episodes i watch like it works
really well and like the pacing's great
and like there's constant like funny
character things happening and like
interesting setups and interesting
scenarios
you know everything from from how our
characters like first introduce
themselves to each other
and like to uh you know like climb the
rope and hoping it doesn't get cut and
falling 100 feet
too certain to make a poop angel
because he falls into the drain hole um
so yeah there's like really good stuff
in there uh
just like yeah the third episode i've
seen i
i i'm going through breaking them down
for you know shoot
so i'm at the fifth episode right now
but so far the third one was my favorite
it's so intense it's just it's there's
like no combat
in the entire episode it's you guys just
like racing around trying to solve the
problems that are happening in the story
but like the intensity level is so high
because it starts with your characters
having not slept
and so there's this constant like do i
have to like lay down and like sleep but
like
there's no time to sleep everything's
coming to an end
and so it's like so intense yeah the
pacing's really good
because also once again it's like we for
every
hour that you see in the show it's about
like two and a half to three hours of
game time right which makes the story
it's just like it's it's it's
streamlined it's at the pace of what you
expect from an entertaining story and
not from a d d
show yeah you know most dd shows cut out
10 minutes 15 minutes just a little bit
of dead time whereas like
we are making conscious decisions yeah
when i say we i have
zero involvement with the edit mostly
it's carmichael
but also natalie and uh matt cairns also
helped yeah you know i was like
going through just really making like
finding the peaks of the story and
putting those together
the one thing like very early on in the
editing process i was talking with
carmichael like after
watching the first cuts they were
keeping in a lot of
the what is it the hypothetical
discussions
and that happens a lot in d d because
you're like hey guys even though we're
at like four different places of the
universe we want to talk about what to
do next
and and so very frequently you do that
or like niko would be like
you know i do have this spell that could
do this and then you no one ever you
never use it
you know and then like jake does the
same thing or d does the same thing i
could do this
i could do that and i'm like cut all
that out
like unless they do it unless they do it
like
so so that way the discussion happens
and it sounds actually way more natural
yeah because it's like characters going
into a problem
and and it's like what are we gonna do
and if there's not like
10 or 15 minutes of like here's all the
different ways we could approach it it's
kind of like uh well
here's how we do it you know and that
way it's i don't know it's so much more
engaging
when you don't have to watch people
actually play in d d and just like
get to absorb the story that happened
from it yeah
yeah it's gonna be awesome um a few
other things going on
on the site as well uh crew cuts season
one is finally coming to a close
wait really how does it just come to a
close like it's never ending
no it's gonna
but just like we did with the vlogs like
there was clear sort of well
you know we bookended them each year and
so
we've been doing crew cuts for almost a
year now
uh there's 90 episodes and
we're gonna wrap that yeah daniel yeah
just wrap it in a nice clean hundred men
like we should that's not a bad
uh yeah it'd be another yeah five weeks
or so um so
and then also something that nick and i
were talking about was doing like
extended reacts
on the site yeah i don't know if you
guys chatted about that
yeah yeah yeah when we watch those clips
and we're like wow
like it gets cut short but like we're
actually saying wow for like
20 seconds
[Laughter]
do you want to talk about that a little
bit more because i mean
what you were saying to me earlier yeah
i mean i think
we are all starting to feel like as we
start to get these
higher profile guests and it's getting
harder and harder to decide what to cut
and what not to cut and i think our
general approach
when editing these videos has come from
our
approach of every other type of video we
make which is
always you know cut the fat keep it lean
mean and just only the best stuff
makes it and that's definitely a good
thing and i think for
certain episodes that works still 15
minutes is like
pretty sweet spot yeah and then you know
you get the brand segment it brings it
to like 18 minutes whatever but
you know if if we have someone who's
like an expert in their field coming in
and it's like a rare opportunity it's
like why not
make those a little bit longer by
cutting less
by cutting less and also you know maybe
we have to get them done in the same
amount of time so
maybe you know balance it out by losing
a little bit of the
illustrious like b-roll pass that we do
because
i made this argument a while back i was
like because i was i never complained
that like you to dean to chase i was
like can you guys just like
make them a little longer like it's okay
to make them a little longer right and
you guys are like
yeah we know but like the longer it is
it requires more time to edit because
then you have more illustrations you
gotta make you have more b-roll you got
to find and fill in and it's like
it's not just simply a matter of cutting
less it's like
the less you uh cut away the more you
have to support
yeah so if only there was like a place
right yeah
these videos up for people who are
passionate about the content we weren't
trying to like win any algorithms or
like get extra clicks but
when people just really wanted it they
could just know where to find it
and we could just give it to them
without any like sacrifices or issues or
considerations for
vimeo
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah we can scream louder there too
because the website can really it can
handle the decibel level that we stream
at
youtube compression cuts it so
no i'm kidding totally just like um
enough that i was like there is there
could be something to that yeah like
does youtube have some sort of like
weird built-in like the reactions are
way more dynamic high dynamic
reaction
you should hear oh look at that neck
from clint and it's full
full dynamic yeah it does like whisper
quiet to like
you know jet engine light oh look at
that
we can bring out our true anime voices
yes we hit all the ranges you know oh
yeah
yeah we should we should start mixing uh
the reacts
like a couple db lower so you can have a
couple moments that really spike
it's like wow
[Laughter]
that's exactly what you'd get from
people you just get it every time
somebody watches the video
yeah i like that so yeah i i think the
rule of thumb should be
we i think we can lax up the
illustrations a little bit yeah
like there's a chance yeah we've gone to
a point where they're like
essay like video essay status
illustrations like
everything is like
everything's illustrated there's custom
graphics on everything and like
if we go a little bit back towards like
the first couple episodes of react style
like where
it would even just spend more time with
you guys on the couch
without having to cut away to stuff
always like if you guys are talking
about a concept
we can stay in that moment and treat it
a little bit more like a podcast style
thing yeah
i think that's that should be the goal
here
and just see it for the website yeah for
the website and honestly
i wouldn't mind making the youtube
videos a little bit more fleshed out too
um
and it always depends on if we have like
the substance toward that yeah at the
end of the day the content needs to be
as long as it needs to be
yes like if it's not feeling right then
it's too long yeah
no and i guess we're just what you're
saying is like
hey we're we're seeing that now that
we're perfecting the current
form of it like it's and we're getting
better and better guests it's starting
to feel like
the content justifies just being longer
and yeah i think in many cases it will
be but also like you know when the
content goes on youtube
it's like you're not only are you
serving it to the people that love that
movie or love visual effects you're also
serving
people that are like interested
generally in movies or like you know
this show or
so you're hitting a lot of different
types of people and you're kind of
making sure that you can straddle
those different worlds whereas you know
if you take that same episode and just
like you know what
the website we're going to add 10
minutes it's just a little more talking
less illustrations
not so much worried about like attention
span just you know give you good stuff
it's like there at least when it's going
on the site it's for people who really
want to watch visual effects artists
react not necessarily
those people plus everybody else on
youtube uh so it's a chance to like
make it directly for the people that to
get what they want
it's it's one of our most consistent
comments i see it
on every single video it's like every
three comments it's like the mortar
holding the bricks together
make these videos longer like i wish
these were longer so
we listened to the comments you know
yeah we read them we can't talk about
who it is
but there's a guest i'm incredibly
excited for hopefully it's going to
happen
so come back to this podcast it's not
neil
yeah well this guest is someone you will
never guess
you will not get michael jordan sorry i
ruined it
there you go that would be so talk about
space jam we're going to react
to space lebron james space jam
me and michael jordan and ren going let
me get that going
great and bad dogs you're gonna need a
bigger couch
speaking of what you know i'm just
kidding christian
came to me he's like yeah we got hit up
by our first couch spawn oh i
saw that too wait for real yeah the ones
that make like the cinema style seating
like yeah leds in this couch like
imagine
imagining 20 things about five feet
apart on the giant chairs
situation here but they're like hey yeah
it officially
wouldn't work for vmxr it's gonna work
because the thing that
makes that show work is the is the
chemistry of the people on the couch
is that proximity kind of forcing us
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what different idea what if you guys
start backwards in
like lazy boy loungers with led lights
you pull a lever and you flip around in
your chair and go hey guys
welcome back just imagine imagine the
couch being like a solid like
13 14 feet long and we're all just like
yeah
it's just like wall-e from wide couch
pixie
yeah yeah it's like the wall-e people
and they're big chairs
part of the charm of the couch is
the bonds it makes i think it's like
even if we don't know a guest we've
never met him it's like
if you sit on a couch like with an arm
in between you
for three hours of a sweaty couch
you're gonna be you're gonna be friends
afterwards yeah dude in years from now
they'll say how you know how they talk
about how people who shook frank
sinatra's hand
and in years from now they'll be like
who sat on the react
oh man i touched nico's hips
with my hips yeah we're gonna
we're gonna kind of like we we signed
the wall back here we want to start
having our guests sign the couch and so
we need a nicer couch on the back of it
this is the couch you that's right
behind you guys
it's too late it's it's too late to
switch back into our dungeon and right
on the wall
sir meanwhile i want to paint over this
wall don't you dare
not really i was just we have some great
signatures right on there
we are [ __ ] logan paul wrote on this
wall
that's right where's his name where is
his name
right above your head ren get there
there it is
that's logan paul's name okay i don't
know probably right right on the frame
no worries
cool dude what's up with all these
freaking people doing crypto scams these
days
that's super easy
guys this is finally a coin i can
believe in and then you check the crypto
history and
he's like he owns 80 of the original
coins from it and it's like
you [ __ ] guy yeah everyone's doing
this now they just come up with a crazy
coin yeah and then they get their like
idiot [ __ ] fans to [ __ ] buy it
and then you mean like you mean like
dogecoin
no that was different that actually
started pretty og that's been around for
a long time
it's the same it's the same like let's
get people hyped on it it's all the hype
though that's the yeah that's what the
game is based on yeah yeah it's like
they get these coins they sell them
value goes up when everyone starts
buying it and then they immediately
liquidate
yeah a bunch of the guys in the phase
clan did that too
i really i i really hope some of these
guys
get like real charges slapped on them
because this is like
it's actual true criminal like fraud
behavior
what kind of what kind of crime would
that be described as like
like well it's not actually traditional
in traditional trading you can't do that
in traditional trading on regular stock
exchanges
okay um because there's a governing body
called the sec that prevents that from
happening
but in in crypto because the
currency isn't regulated by those bodies
there is no there is a regulatory body
that says
you've committed a federal crime and now
you're going to jail i mean but it's
like if
at the simplest it's just fraud you know
you can get charged with that
i think i think what constitutes the
crime rent is when they go
i'm gonna back this i'm holding on to it
i'm not
personally invested in it yeah and then
it's like i actually am selling all of
it on day one like yeah
when they do actions that directly
conflict the messages they're giving
them
that's definition fraud yeah i mean it
it feels very morally wrong i just
didn't know how technically it would be
yeah it would be statements that cause
another to act in their detriment
i just feel like false government
institutions aren't able to handle the
fact there's like you know
almost 400 million people living in the
united states now like it's one thing
when it's like
100 million people and there's like
government bureaucracies built up to
like handle stuff and now it's like
there's so many people and there's so
many
things like that happening it's all over
the place it's all these like
brand new things with new technology and
it's like how do you keep up how do you
apply old laws old
regulations old like there's like a
thousand cryptocurrencies right now or
something i think if you went back
to when to the early 1900s when the
population of the united states was 100
million people that
you'd probably have the exact same
thought you're right yeah how do we
apply these
yeah you just have to teach people not
to fall for stupid stuff like that
unfortunately
you know there's always going to be
somebody there's always a lesson that
costs you
everybody gets that lesson and you just
hope it doesn't cost you too much you
guys ever had that lesson what's like
the most
what was your like okay i'll keep my eye
out for these
in the future i gotta think about that
one let's see here
i think there's any big one for me per
se
it's probably something small those when
i was like yeah i'm 20
likes there was one of those scams where
you they
they they uh write you a check for more
than what the
purchase value is and then you're
supposed to cash it and take those
oh i heard about that yeah and i almost
fell for one of those when i was like 20
because i was naive and i almost fell
for it but
yeah yeah scams man i woke up one day
uh to a phone call from my dad
and i was like hello he's like ren i was
like
yeah he's like and i can tell he was
really upset
and i was like what's going on and it
turns out my grandparents had almost
gotten scammed
by basically someone called up my
grandma and convinced her that i had
gone down to mexico for a wedding
and that i was thrown in jail and that
they needed to pay ten thousand dollars
bail to get me out of there and they had
spent apparently a couple hours trying
to track me down
all this stuff and none of them thought
to just call me
and tell my dad was like he did it and i
he was angry at me at first like how
dare you be okay in this situation
but really he was just mad at himself
and then like he very quickly kind of
came around me like wait i'm
there's absolutely no reason for me to
be angry at you right now
we'll figure this out everything's okay
your grandparents are okay
i'm okay i'll be okay and i was like
yeah good morning there's some super
satisfying youtube channels like uh yeah
i think it's like
justice yes oh man those are
just one of my favorites right now yes
i miss the classic nigerian prince
emails it's kind of like
heartwarming and wholesome it's like ah
the prince is reaching out to me for
help
i can save his kingdom it's like i'm
down
it's like the beginning of a video game
i'm down for that yeah let's do it i can
be a duke in your country okay
yeah dude did you know that uh
you can this is old news but you can
purchase a
official title baron duke
really yeah so there's nigeria no no
it is technically a sovereign nation
built on an old oil platform
is that the oil right it's not it's an
oil platform it's an observation it's an
observation
from world war ii but still a giant
man-made thing yeah right
out off the coast of england and it's
like i guess they've just declared
like dual residency and stuff yeah you
can get citizenship do you have to have
like a passport nick and i were gonna go
take it with ar-15s but we decided
that's right
yeah jake we should revisit that vlog by
the way yeah yeah
excuse me i know i know you can i forget
it i think
jake and nick take over a small country
no but i i know you can in in scotland
there's this dude with a bunch of land
and he's selling off like tiny chunks of
it that are just
gonna become a lord oh really yeah
because you have like
it's the most tangible like version of
this thing you know like
buy a star buy some real estate all
these like kind of frivolous
be it lord nothings yeah but this one's
like oh
like this is cool here's how he's doing
this
i read i read about this guy he's he you
in in order to be a lord
in scotland you have to have you have to
look into this
land itself and so he what he does is he
sells you a foot
by a foot of land and then puts a tree
on it
and then that's that's your scottish
land
and you're you're the lord of that you
know
well what happens when the tree grows
bigger than that plot
of land you climb the tree i think he
slices them out
then you have to have a war then you
have to have a war with the other
yeah with the other five people around
you whoever you marry so i'm gonna
you go to scotland and you find your
tree and then you start chopping down
the other trees
[Laughter]
and you're like i'm taking this over and
then you use those trees to make a fort
around you could build a treehouse in
the tree because the airspace
might be wait i'm gonna google becoming
a scottish lord
yeah i'm confused though how does owning
land just mean
so it's the feudal system the origins of
the feudal system required
require that like a tree but don't a lot
of people in scotland own land
are they all lords
as far as i understand at least it was
this way back in the day i do not know
if it's this way now because i'm not an
i'm not a uk lawyer but in order for you
to be a lord in the middle ages you had
to own
land of some kind um you you that was
because the feudal system was a currency
of land it was
literally that's that was the currency
that's how it was so
everything was done that's why it's
called so i guess everyone has every
landowner in scotland is the lord
yeah like what's the big deal it's
simple one square foot is 50
10 square feet is 350 dollars however
yeah you want to split however
it's a dedicated plot of land can we be
co-lords
i don't know if you actually own it a
dedicated like when someone pronounces
collab like collab it doesn't matter if
you go to scotland
and you're not recognized as a lord then
it's meaningless
well can you put it on your passport
that's because apparently
apparently the sealand thing you can
like put it on all your legal paperwork
which is the funny part to me like
to have i want meaningful land ownership
i need
actual government titles please here's
the thing does that change your tax
situation
i wonder so these are souvenir plots the
plots of land themselves are recognized
and referred to as souvenir plots in
scotland
though some those souvenir plots are
typically too small to be registered
with the scottish land registry directly
we maintain our own private records and
take our arrangements with our lords and
ladies
very seriously yes so it sounds like
some mcdonald's lordship
right here
yeah can i build on my plot every
lordship or ladyship title pack
contributes to the preservation and
protection of woodland areas
as the intention is for the land to be
kept in its natural state we ask that
all interested parties do bear this in
mind
so that sounds like a yes it sounds like
we don't want you to but you can build
on it
dude that that's that sounds literally
like when you get freaking fortnite and
you buy that
that bag of gold coins for five bucks
okay so wren feudalism okay right
feudalism the dominant social system in
medieval europe in which nobility held
lands from the crown in exchange for
military service and vassals were in
turn tenants of the nobles
i remember social studies i mean
i'm not really questioning what why that
i'm talking about in today's modern age
you can just literally buy a foot of
land and be like i'm a lord now you can
become a laird lord or lady
where does somebody just owns land in
scotland it's arcane
laird versus lord you want to be a laird
or a lord
i'd rather be a lord okay
whatever lizard so yeah they they own
the land they're just dedicating us
whatever to you but you they get you it
says you can visit any time
including midnight it's just like some
dude's backyard
it
it's like you have to go through the
side gate
it's like i'm allowed here it's like
what are you doing i thought i was
allowed here don't you speak to me like
that you know you speak to me like a
peasant
i can stay up as late as i want this one
foot plot of land
so when you say it when you say when you
say ground
refugees
[Laughter]
you're good you wouldn't actually be
somebody's lord though unless they lived
on your land i mean who knows
it's good man any unfortunate referred
to a lord of
the land as a lord yeah is that where
the name landlord comes from yes that is
yeah so is the owner of this lord
we just start calling him lord steve
lords
the fetal system part of the feudal
system was those lords were required to
fight for their lord if he so choose to
call up his banners so
if the guy who owns the backyard wants
to go pick a fight with his neighbor do
we have to go out and we would
we would okay everyone's so
unhappy about income inequality these
days and i'm wondering if we give it
that fun like
fantasy twist
people kind of like get into it like we
get into the red fair
[Laughter]
oh
i mean i think people could get into
that you know defuse the tension
oh my gosh so if everyone's a lord
though who is the lord
is anyone a lord well some people don't
own a foot of land
scotland so you're better than them
did the reviews on the website where i
know to get sanford's birthday now
a lordship i will i will put it on my
driver's license
samsung la lord oh yeah you are i'm a
lord
you're already a lawyer i am a
california an american lord
i have no loads above me sorry guys uh
noble titles are banned in this country
oh damn damn [ __ ] that's right ceo
you're just one of us sam you're on the
same level as anyone else
no serves for you there goes the whole
role-playing
experience you guys
convert those gold coins into actual
paper dollars
you'd have to pass a constitutional
amendment in order to make your
little fantasy possible damn so the red
fair is
just a protected area yeah it's illegal
it's technically illegal
we could go to a to a native american uh
nation and then ask them if they want to
have lords and ladies
and then they could say yes and that is
a tough sell
that is going to be hard man
the native americans fought against the
british
oh my gosh
it might be a hard sell but i bought my
my fireworks from royalty
oh yeah yeah you have no idea that's a
tough
tough sell i mean if it was like a
french like
duke or something maybe you'd have a
better chance because the native
americans and the french were
pretty they were close yeah yeah because
yeah the the french and indian war
where they all fought against the
british together well yeah i mean there
was both sides
native americans on both sides of all
those wars
isn't it weird that we're like we know
that we're not in india
we're so like yeah indians like isn't
that weird
yeah it's kind of weird yeah i think i i
don't know i i think people overreact
to that a little bit just it's weird
it's a little weird i mean i get it but
it's still a little weird
i mean most people say native americans
we analyzed everything
that's weird if we understood the
origins of all of our words
we would like i don't know
jake stop being a dork that's a little
throwback to our lives
you understand the etymology of all the
words that we use
um i'm not probably shocked
yeah that is true that is true yeah well
then what's america's original name
you know it's like [ __ ] that's a weird
name amerigo vespucci
mario v but what was it called before
him oh man it was called uh
god i i should know this it's like a
viking thing right yeah it was like some
uh
well i'll get back to you on that one it
was middle earth
but then but then whatever just watching
a thing too
what was it called before that
probably something called something like
mother you know like native tongue
whatever tribe she's called it oh yeah i
don't want to leave people hanging
listening to this
because they're probably googling it
right now are you asking what did the
europeans call it a
comment down below yeah after the fact
who are you referring to
who called it what who called it what i
don't know did anyone call it anything
i'm sure what is that place
what place that place right there
like people also ask what did the native
americans call america
turtle island yeah yeah okay hold on
no i mean googling google is a creation
myth there is a creation
myth that i just think that's kind of
funny the big island on the back of the
turtle
guys i know i've heard about the turtle
thing but yeah googling a question but
not just in the terms of turning
a question that says what did the
native americans call america yeah most
like very reductive that's like saying
i know no i didn't google that i didn't
google that but that was what google was
like saying did you mean that
oh no it wasn't me it was google you
mean all these people who lived here had
all these
all their own cultures what did what did
they all call it and they all spoke
different languages what did they call
it yeah we don't know
it's not googleable right there yeah
that's not
googleable you gotta ask jeeves
is what became new finland oh nice i'm
glad he didn't call america
finland i've been lame all right dodge
that one
united states of finland like dear pause
like so milo's learning her alphabet and
her one two threes and all that kind of
stuff right now
do you ever pause to like think about
how it's weird that we've all just
culturally agreed upon a coming before b
and b like alphabet alphabetical order
we're all just like
yeah sure it's no longer it's literally
called the alphabet
nico i know but we're just like we all
just at some point agreed on the
standard
we're like yes all right because how
else do you communicate with
language
well i mean it's like never
question so much of what we learn and
that just gets passed on
for a long time yeah and the alphabet
because
if we were sitting there bickering about
who what letters came first we would
never actually make my whole progress
i feel like it's like i'm like what
should we call this
and we all give our votes like we gotta
pick one
thing to call it you know it's not like
i'm not calling that a can i'm calling
it a freaking duty
and it's like all right so remember each
time he says duty he's talking about the
can
it's like okay that's gonna get annoying
after a while i mean i can't help it if
i'm
bilingual okay
i speak gibberish and english
[Laughter]
you're oh so totally
well the origins of the alphabet go back
to the greeks nico
that's true and so there's been a long
line of people who have found it useful
to progress humanity with the
functional ordering of an alphabet and
therefore there's really no reason for
us to go back in and go
you know what why doesn't c come before
b you're right
you know probably thinks that it's like
it's a little too bad that we like
solidified the keyboard layout and we
didn't quite optimize it before it
happened
i know it's gonna be so hard to re-learn
how to type for the more optimized yeah
like you're really committed to like the
qwerty keyboard and now it's like it is
part of human culture
and will be forever and it's like well i
hope you're all happy with qwerty
that's what we came up with i'm pissed
that s is so far in the alphabet because
we use that all the way
as corty is winning they made courtney
to freaking make hits of people on
typewriters that's actually a little bit
a little a little bit of a myth kind of
is it it's it's not that they can't type
fast it's that's the like
it's made it spread out so that when you
are typing fast
and using the most common letters
they're not in a spot where they'll
stack up on each other as quickly
sure so the your typewriter went jam
right
so i guess it's still typewriter legacy
man
still gotta get the typewriter support
dude people who are into typewriters
sorry that's that's it people were in
at one point i'm just saying they had no
other choices inside of a typewriter
people that
he's saying people that were into oh
yeah i know yeah
this guy on tick knock tick tock names
stage door johnny who does a lot of like
he points out a lot of the weird
inconsistencies about language that we
just completely take for granted about
how
words have different pronunciations even
though they have the exact same
spellings or different spellings for
absolutely no reason
for like you know plural or not plural
it's like yeah what the [ __ ] up with
the letter c
yeah exactly so is he an etymologist of
sorts
i guess i mean yeah perhaps i don't know
i mean he's a tick talker
when you're talking there a little
bubble
just no influencer it was about the size
of like half of a grain of rice and
floated through the air and then popped
did it really i've seen that happen to
other people before it finally happened
you made a speech bubble it's an actual
bubble an actual speech
it came out a full sphere and like i saw
like i thought it was just a piece of
dust and what is that and then just
disappears from like
some saying look closely you see a word
there and you're like you look closely
like ooh
i can't
i've seen other people do that too like
a tiny little like bubble that that's
why
it's just yeah it's like oh
green bubble it's weird also like why is
android green and iphone's blue
who decided that they just committed to
it probably because someone would get
sued
because it's like you get sued over that
kind of garbage yeah
you know you know people have to make
decisions in order to create things
right
that's why it's like they're messy is
that anything
like this yes someone decided that it
would be green probably because it's an
easy on the eyes and it's high contrast
for the white letters and it's easy to
or black letters and it's easy to read
from but the blue color why are the
premium experiences circle
shape that's a circular phone or
triangle triangle aspect
phone text white or black in the chat
texting window i think it depends if you
have dark mode
it's black it's black it's white i
thought it was white
it's totally white i feel like i feel
like nico's on dark mode
are you on mushrooms right now i i am
not man i am not
but i like the fact that we couldn't
actually remember the color of the text
it's both
oh my text is white sending to my wife
but her text in the gray bubble coming
back is black
jesus christ
who decided that we don't need mushrooms
guys
we have these thoughts all on our own
we blow our minds just sitting here yeah
yeah language is cool english is really
cool
[Music]
yeah like decide on a canon like you put
this in a cup holder it's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes anyways skinny tacos yeah of
observational humor
all right let's wrap this one up bros
all right oh man
right an hour and a half to wrap it up
that was a ridiculous episode you guys
if you made it this far congratulations
to a hundred more may all you lords and
ladies out there
listen to a hundred more episodes
more episodes with the lords and ladies
of the corridor
don't forget the lairds oh yeah the
lighter layer the lad
and the barons the bears can i give us a
remix sam
anyone who comments as a baron for sure
dude yeah anybody who comments in this
video i'll give them a
king status and queen status
[Music]
okay this is all right hey everybody
thank you for listening to our podcast
we really appreciate it it's an awesome
experience having
discussions and getting to see the
conversations continued in the comments
okay christian you ready and three two
one